wasn't able to start training camp on
time this I believe 10 days of practice
[Applause]
throw it downfield a little go
round on Jackson Smith and jigba
adjusting to the football and it has to
feel good for the true freshman to
connect on something deep downfield
touchdown Buckeyes
[Applause]
Stroud delivers short and Smith and
Jacob breaks free takes your tackles to
foot race and they finally run him down
near the 15-yard line Joey Porter saved
a touchdown but an electric play but I
want you to keep an eye on 16. Brown Jr
Brown has to make the tackle to catch
but a poor angle right there middle of
those runs in the midst of those runs
this defense has got to maintain their
proximity CJ Stroud to Smith and jig
book great move gets down the sideline
and a burr Smith and
down Buckeyes
touchdown Ohio State this is just an
ordinary route he's just going to run
just inside he gets the completion but
then it's turned the Jets on and watch
his partner down the edge that's Chris
olave the unselfish hustle getting down
the field and getting just enough of a
block right there this guy's release is
ridiculous and yet the ball still jumps
out of his hand
jsn coming around and he finds space
Jackson Smith and Jimbo
and marking him out at the 21-yard line
on the end of the line of scrimmage go
out and secure and look how long is to
hold this block I mean forever he does
so beautifully against Jalen Graham to
allow Jackson Smith and jigba and the
hot streak continues for number 11 of
the Buckeyes